so have you guys seen the the pictures
of this black hole I'm sure you did it
was all over the internet yesterday I
mean it's amazing it really is amazing
and it annoys me so much that all of
these idiots online yesterday we're
talking about how disappointing it is
and how how anti-climatic
do you have any idea when you look at
that picture do you have any idea what
you're looking at first of all this is a
thing that scientists theorized about
based on mathematical calculations a
hundred years ago and now here we have
discovered it isn't isn't that crazy
that they could do that that someone
could just work out a math problem and
say well so according to this there
should be massive holes in space that
suck in all the light and energy around
them and crush it into non-existence and
then we look into a telescope but we say
oh yeah well there it is right there I
mean and speaking of looking into a
telescope um this thing is 55 million
light years away 55 million light years
do you have any idea how far away that
is a light year is five trillion miles
so this is 55 million times five
trillion you know and that you know what
that number is I don't know what that
number is that's out it's it's it's
really really really big let's put it
that way so it is so far that you could
travel at the speed of light which is
670 million miles an hour fast enough to
travel around the entire globe seven
times in one second you could be going
that fast and it would take you 55
million years at that speed to get there
if you started heading there at the dawn
of human civilization okay you would
still have right now oh another 55
million years to go you you basically
wouldn't have even started your journey
yet you would still be you would still
be so early in your trip that if you
realized you left your wallett back on
earth you might as well turn around and
go get it because that's how vast the
distances are that we're dealing with
and and and I mean if that doesn't blow
your mind then you must not have a mind
that can be blown in the first place I
mean come on folks come on eat oh and by
the way this black hole okay it's it's
it's mass is seven billion
times greater than the Sun you could
plop our entire solar system and
everything it contains inside it the Sun
is just a speck of dust in comparison to
this thing the Sun compared to this
black hole is like you compared to the
earth itself
but we're all disappointed because it's
blurry oh it's blurry
yeah the image the image of the thing
that's millions of quadrillion miles
away is blurry oh it's so black oh I'm
sorry about that I'm sorry we couldn't
get it in hi-def for you I'm sorry that
this image that took 55 million years to
get to your eyeballs is is blurry
oh I you know I'm so sorry oh yeah yes
what's that that's so disappointing
meanwhile a stupid trailer for the Lion
King was released on the same day as
this image of the black hole and that
Lion King trailer is literally just a
slightly more realistic cartoon which is
a verbatim shot-for-shot remake of
another cartoon which only came out 25
years ago yet that got a bigger reaction
than the image of the black hole people
were astounded by that they said my god
look at this cartoon you see that lion
he almost looks like a real lion I mean
this car to look at this cartoon it's
amazing it's beautiful that's what
impressed everybody not the black hole
55 million light years away we are
living in an idiocracy folks that's what
we're living we are we are surrounded we
are being we are living in a black hole
of stupidity and we're all being crushed
to death by it anyway let's see what
else is going on today Julian Assange
was arrested today that's the big story
now to be honest I need to read more
about what's going on here in order to
deliver an opinion worth listening to
I'm not sure if I'm supposed to admit
that you know but there it is one thing
I don't like about this job is that
people expect you to automatically have
a worthwhile and informed opinion about
everything that happens to occur in the
news right and that's what people expect
and I think that when people watch a
show like this or any other show or you
know cable news show or anything like
that and they see people pontificating
and offering their opinion they just
assume that okay well this person must
be omniscient that they that they you
know can can be informed about
everything all the time and have an
opinion worth listening to but the the
dirty little secret is that it's all you
know it's all basically a camera trick I
mean the people that are in this line of
work because of course we can't have
worthwhile opinions about everything and
we can't automatically have all the
information immediately in order to
deliver a worthwhile opinion so a lot of
times people end up doing is that they
even if they don't really know anything
about the subject they just kind of look
at what other people in their same
ideological vein are saying about a
particular thing and then they they just
calibrate their point of view based on
that now I prefer not to do that I want
to have my own perspective but it takes
it takes time to develop that sometimes
and so maybe i'll already visit this
this later if you'll forgive me for that
this story was just breaking this
morning as i was preparing to talk about
other things thinking about other things
like for instance this there was an
essay that was published just yesterday
yesterday was a big day i mean get the
black hole blind king and then you also
had this an essay published from pope
benedict about the the abuse crisis in
the church it's a fascinating document
in many respects benedict basically
argues that agents of change in the
church agents of rebellion really of
sabotage you might say sought in the 60s
and 70s to create a new church a new
church that's how we put it in quotes
one that is modeled after the morality
of the world rather than natural law in
the bible and this led to moral chaos
which led to the sexual abuse crisis
that has plagued the church ever since
that's his basic case let me read
some of this to you here he is talking
about what kinds of situations developed
in the 60s he says in various seminaries
homosexual cliques were established
which acted more or less openly and
significantly changed the climate in the
seminaries in one Seminary in southern
Germany candidates for the priesthood
and candidates for lay Ministry of the
pastoral specialists lived together at
the common meal seminarians and pastoral
specialists ate together the married
among the laymen sometimes accompanied
by the wives and children and on
occasion by their girlfriends the
climate in the seminary could not
provide support for the preparation to
the priestly vocation he goes on indeed
in many parts of the church conciliar
attitudes were understood to mean having
a critical or negative attitude towards
the hitherto existing tradition which is
now which was now to be replaced by a
new radically open relationship with the
world one bishop who had previously been
seminary rector had arranged for the
seminarians to be shown pornographic
films allegedly with the intention of
thus making them resistant to behavior
contrary to the faith they were not only
the United States of America in Davitt
there were not only in the United States
of America individual bishops who
rejected the Catholic tradition as a as
a whole and sought to bring about a kind
of new modern Catholic cath cath licit
II there we go
in their diocese perhaps it is worth
mentioning that in not a few seminary
students caught reading my books were
considered unsuitable for the priesthood
he goes on the idea of a better Church
created by ourselves is in fact a
proposal of the devil with which he
wants to lead us away from the Living
God through a deceitful logic by which
we are too easily duped okay so you see
he's there he's there diagnosing the
problem and pointing not to see the
problem is that a lot of people in the
church today especially church leaders
when they're discussing the sexual abuse
epidemic and all the issues in the
church they're always looking for
practical cause
is practical solutions you know
everything is very practical very kind
of earthbound they're not looking deeper
it what is the spiritual moral root of
the problem which I mean this is a moral
problem right so you you have to speak
of it on those terms
now Benedict is willing to do that and
then he talks about died now his his
ideas about remedying the problem I
think are worth quoting at length he
says what must be done
perhaps we should create another church
for things to work out well that
experiment has already been undertaken
and has already failed only obedience
and love for our Lord Jesus Christ can
point the way so let us first try to
understand anew and from within what the
Lord wants and has wanted with us
first I would suggest the following if
we really wanted to summarize very
briefly the content of the faith as laid
down in the Bible we might do so by
saying that the Lord has initiated a
narrative of love with us and wants to
subsume all creation in it the counter
force against evil which threatens us
and the whole world can ultimately only
consist in our entering into this love
it is the real counter force against
evil the power of evil arises from our
refusal to love God he who entrusts
himself to the love of God is redeemed
our being our being not redeemed as a
consequence of our inability to love God
learning to love God is therefore the
path of human Redemption let's see I
mean there's I'm not going to read this
whole thing but a society without God a
society that does not know him and
treats him as non-existent is a society
that loses its measure in our day the
catch phrase of God's death was coined
when God does die in a society it
becomes free we were assured in reality
the death of God in the society also
means the end of freedom because what
dies is the purpose that provides
orientation and because the compass
disappears that points us in the right
direction by teaching us to distinguish
good from evil
he goes on this is the case with
pedophilia it was theorized only a short
time ago it's quite legitimate but it
has spread further and further and now
we realize with shock that things are
happening to our children and young
people that threatened to destroy them
the fact that this could also spread in
the church and among priests ought to
disturb us in particular why did
pedophilia reach such proportions
ultimately the reason is the absence of
God we Christians and priests also
prefer not to talk about God because
this speech does not seem practical and
then he goes on from there I mean it's
worth I'm not gonna read the whole thing
I I wish I we worth doing but I won't I
would recommend that you do so though
and and so everything he's saying here
is good it's on on point it's necessary
and it's true but it raises in my mind a
whole separate question which is this
why did this man leave the papacy in the
first place I mean why did he retire
it's been now six years six years since
he left and he's still clearly on top of
things clearly he understand what's
going on in the church he understands
understands it better than the current
occupant of the chair I would say and
he's interested in providing leadership
which is why he he wrote this this essay
so why isn't he in the lead it's strange
to me it's a strange situation yeah he's
an old man he's I think he's 90 or 91
but Pope Francis is no spring chicken
either Francis is 82 or 83 years old
himself now it would be different in my
mind if Benedict was sitting there in
retirement writing the occasional essay
while a pope in his 50s a real reformer
was in there in the Vatican kickin butt
taking names shaping things up putting
the church back on the right path then I
would say that this is the best of both
worlds that we have because you would
have the elder statesmen former Pope
who's old and retired and he's sitting
to the side providing advice here and
there direction while the man with with
energy and vigor has his sleeves rolled
up right and and he's getting the job
that no that would make sense that would
be a dynamic that would make a lot of
sense to me but that's not the dynamic
we see in the church today what we have
is an old retired Pope sitting off to
the side while another old Pope who is
in his 80s is in there doing very little
to address the problem and in the
meantime is sowing more confusion and
discord in the church with his obscure
and strange pronouncements on every
subject Under the Sun so that situation
makes no sense to me at all in its very
bizarre so on one hand it's great to
hear this truth from Benedict but on the
other hand it's kind of disturbing
because I think the assumption was when
Benedict stepped down six years ago
yeah the assumption was that six years
in the future
you know 2019 he wouldn't be alive
anymore I mean we all thought what he's
stepping down he must be on death's door
so I don't think anyone thought that
we'd be heading into 2020 and Benedict
would still be around the fact that he's
still around it's like well where did
you go why did you leave a lot of
questions are raised there that's all
I'll say
all right now The Daily Caller
had a report yesterday about an alleged
blacklist that's kept by Google which
singles out certain people and websites
and and tries to tries to mess with them
now I'm gonna read a little bit from
from their report and stick around for
the twist ending here okay so it says
this according to Daily Caller says
Google does manipulate its search
results manually contrary to the
company's official denials documents
obtained by the Daily Caller indicate
two official policies dubbed the
misrepresentation policy and the quote
good neighbor policy inform the
company's xpa news blacklist with list
which is maintained by Google's trust
and safety team the deceptive news
domain blacklist is going to be used by
many search features to filter
maduk sites that violate the
good-neighbor misrepresentation policies
that according to the to the document
the document chain by the caller says
the purpose of the blacklist will be to
bar the sites from surfacing in any
search feature or news product it will
not cause a demotion in the organic
search results or DND Index them
altogether what that means is that
targeted sites will not be removed from
the quote ten blue links portion of the
search results but the blacklist apply
applies to most of the other search
features like top news videos or the
various sidebars that are returned as
search results okay so let me get to the
as I said the the twist ending on the
blacklist are a number of conservative
sites including Gateway pundit Matt
Walsh's blog
Gary North's blog Tea Party economist
calm Caroline glicks web site
conservative Tribune which is a property
of the Western journal and the website
of the American Spectator okay so yeah
so I'm I'm on there according to Daily
Caller I'm I'm there I made the black
list so I'm on the I made the team I was
picked varsity what's interesting though
is that my my my blog now is just
basically my it contains my contact
information you can find links to my
written work on my website Matt Walsh
blog comms you wanna go check it out so
if you go there it's now for for a few
years I was that's how I got started I
was writing on this blog and that's what
I did
and that's where all my content went but
now you know my written content goes to
the daily wire before that it went to
the blaze I haven't written unique
content on the bat walls blog in like
four years but as I said so if you go to
my website there's contact information
for me and there's there's links to to
my written work which will take you to
the blaze or to daily wire yet even in
spite of that according to this
apparently it's been blacklisted I don't
I don't know anything about it you know
I've had a couple of
media outlets try to get a hold of me
and you know want to interview me about
being blacklisted by google i-i-i don't
have anything to tell you I have no
perspective on it because I found out
about it from the Daily Caller
that's all I know but I do know that the
the blacklisting you know blacklisting
online is a real thing it's been a real
thing and I think we all know that but
these companies are smart about it and
this is this is the point I want to make
these companies are smart about the way
they do it
and so with with with Google okay it's
not like now I mentioned on Twitter
yesterday that I was that I had been
cited as a blacklisted site and a bunch
of people responded by say oh yeah well
I just typed your name into Google and
you came right up so clearly you're not
blacklisted yeah but according to this
to this report that's not the way the
blacklist works yeah it's they're not
just gonna scrub you from the internet
completely that would be way too obvious
so yeah if you go and you google Matt
Walsh I'm gonna pop up you're gonna
you're gonna see me there it's one of
the first results so they're they're a
little bit more subtle about it which
makes it easier to get away with and
it's also not always clear what the what
criteria is being used which is part of
the problem now obviously none of these
sites are ever going to admit that they
have any criteria to to to you know
target conservative sites so they might
not admit to the criteria but we all
know that they have it but even even
with these various sites the the
criteria they use to target
conservatives that is not consistent
there's an arbitrariness to it so I'm
blacklisted by Google apparently but
meanwhile twitter has never once
suspended me I mean knock on wood
Twitter has never once suspended me or
anything I've never been I've never had
any problem with with Twitter even
though Twitter has suspended and
expelled many people who have smaller
followings than I do and who have said
things that are much less controversial
than what I say on a daily basis I mean
I I see the kinds of things that get
people kicked off of Twitter and every
time I see a story like that I think
I say stuff like that every day I've
said I've said things are far harsher
than that you know not that I'm trying
to not that I'm asking for it here but
it so it's interesting then Facebook as
well has as far as I know has never
really never really monkeyed with me but
Google has and Wikipedia has I'm
apparently not allowed to have a
Wikipedia page it seems people have told
me at various times over the years that
I that I've got a Wikipedia entry up and
then and and then it's deleted and then
someone else put another one up that's
deleted and this has happened several
times over the years where I guess
someone tries to put it up and then it's
always taken down and so I'm not allowed
to have a Wikipedia page so it seems
like I've been blacklisted by Google
Wikipedia not by Facebook and Twitter
but there are other conservatives who
clearly have been blacklisted by the
social media sites but not so much by by
Google or Wikipedia or any of those
sites and that's the way it works and
this is what makes it this is what makes
it hard to navigate the censorship
online it's precisely the fact that all
of these gatekeepers don't coordinate
and they don't do it exactly the same
way they all seem to basically agree
that they want to de-emphasize
conservative content but they seem to
pick on different people for different
reasons at different times and and
that's how they get away with it and
it's it's all quite nefarious but that's
fun anyway to be blacklisted by Google
maybe I'll get that on a t-shirt
blacklisted by Google alright let's go
to emails because I got a bunch of
interesting ones most of which I will
not be able to get to but Matt wall show
at gmail.com Matt wall show at gmail.com
is the email address this is from Dave
says hey Matt I've been a reader and
listener of yours for quite a while now
I started back in the days when you were
a lowly alpaca groomer anyway when I
first started reading your stuff I was a
new Christian and not a very deep
thinker on Biblical issues you've really
helped me open up it's a much deeper
thinking on issues of spiritual
significance and all my time reading
your stuff and following your podcasts
I've never heard your opinions or
beliefs about biblical end times
prophecy I am a Pentecostal
Christiaan of the non snake-handling
variety that's good and essentially my
beliefs boil down to this there is an
event that is imminent meaning this
event could curd occurred anytime known
commonly as the rapture in which
Christians will be removed from the
earth similarly to the way Christ has
taken up after the resurrection or
Elijah has taken up after he passes the
mantle to Elijah or John and his vision
on Patmos following this event is a time
known as the Great Tribulation or the
time of Jacob's trouble the Great
Tribulation is a period of seven years
in which the world will be judged and a
political figure rises to power in the
earth who has incredible demonic power
from Satan himself known as the
Antichrist a lot is prophesied to happen
during this world's this world leaders
reign that I don't necessarily care to
split hairs over but at the end of the
Antichrist seven-year reign Jesus
returns in physical form once again this
time Jesus comes not as a baby but as a
conqueror who destroys the Antichrist
and his armies in the final battle of
the world these beliefs are based on my
pastors teachings books I've read on the
subject and in my own reading of the
books of the Bible like Daniel Isaiah
Jeremiah Matthew and Revelation thanks
for taking the time to read this and
give me your thoughts on this topic PS
not that I'm one of these guys who are
incessantly trying to identify who the
Antichrist is but I'm fairly certain it
isn't ben ben shapiro yeah yeah but
there was there was a that's in
reference to yeah i'm fairly sure it's
fairly certain it isn't ben shapiro
either as michael knowles pointed out i
don't know what kind of antichrist would
hire a bunch of christians to work for
him there was some some idiotic stupid
christian was on TV a few days ago
saying that ben shapiro
you know christians shouldn't be
listening to ben shapiro because he's if
not the antichrist he's an antichrist
so idiotic anyway thanks dave for for
for that for being a loyal reader and
listener as well let me try to work
through this with you first of all as it
pertains to the rapture my problem with
the rapture which which I which I do not
believe in is that it is unquestionable
a new doctrine it was invented by John
Darby in the 19th century nobody was
talking about the rapture before that
the Church Fathers weren't talking about
it the theologians of the Middle Ages
weren't talking about it the reformers
weren't talking about it no it felt that
John Darby apparently to be the one guy
who sees it almost almost 2,000 years he
he says oh yeah though it's right there
the whole time
I just I don't buy that I I'm always
skeptical when somebody you know 19 or
20 centuries later notices something in
the text that nobody noticed before but
more importantly than you know what any
theologian throughout history was saying
is that the by the the biblical writers
we're not talking about in any rapture
either
I mean what's what's the one verse that
almost everybody immediately cites to
prove the rapture well they go right to
Matthew 24:40 right where it says the
two men will be in a field one will be
taken won't be left two women will be
grinding at the mill one will be taken
and one will be left okay
now even just out of context I'm not
sure that it that that that you have
here is strong enough hook to hang a
whole mythology of rapture on so you
think about how much has grown out of
just those two sentences and this is the
problem people feel free to just take
any sentence or two in Scripture and to
go to town on it and come up with an
entire new system a whole new theology a
whole new all of these new you know
predictions and everything based on
based on you know one or two sentences
that they find in Scripture and in this
case that practice is all the more
absurd when you look at it in context so
let's do that okay let's look at this
supposed prediction of the rapture in
context it says but about that day or
hour no one knows not even the angels in
heaven nor the son but only the father
as it was in the days of Noah so it will
be at the coming of the Son of Man for
in the days before the flood people were
eating and drinking marrying and giving
and giving in marriage up to the day
Noah entered the Ark and they knew
nothing about what would happen until
the flood came and took the
all away that is how it will be at the
coming of the Son of Man two men will be
in the field one will be taken the other
left two men will be grinding with the
hand mill one will be taken the other
left therefore keep watch because you do
not know on what day the Lord will come
so the person taken in this image here
is the unrighteous the wicked Jesus is
talking about the destruction of the
wicked for the days before the flood
people were eating and drinking marrying
and giving in marriage up to the day
Noah entered the Ark and they knew
nothing about what would happen until
the flood came and took them all away
this is how it will be at the coming of
the Son of Man one will be taken well
what's taken we did you said it took the
the wicked people were taken away and
not just at the blink of an eye like
disappeared I mean there was a flood
right and and I'm not saying that he's
he's not saying that at the end of the
world there's gonna be another flood but
the point is the wicked were washed away
were taken I believe in some
translations even the word seized is
used which makes it a little bit more
clear seized so this to me clearly
explicitly is talking about wicked
people being destroyed it is not talking
about good people being ascended into
heaven it's just it's just not so the
rapture folks have twisted this verse to
mean the exact opposite of what it
actually means which is incredible
really when you think about it because
all you have to do you know I'm not
gonna try to attack you I don't mean
that I don't mean any disrespect I'm
just saying if I don't if you read that
verse and its context I don't know how
you come to any other conclusion right
it's it's really clear what he's saying
but notice something else that Jesus
says he says you won't know when the end
is coming okay you will not expect it so
if you're expecting the end that's a
good sign that it's not going to come if
anything because Jesus says you won't
expect it stop looking for it you're not
gonna know sorry and I think that's what
Jesus
as for verses in in Daniel and in
revelation well I've read those books
also and I would recommend that for
everyone to actually sit down and read
the book of Revelation cover to cover
not just a verse here and there not just
the things that your pastor points out
and I mean it's it's good to you know to
also get guidance on on these things as
well but but if you actually sit down
and read it yourself like cover to cover
right do that and then tell me whether
you could make heads or tails of it
because I don't think you can I can't I
don't think anybody can the book is
heavily heavily heavily metaphorical I
don't think you can just crack open the
book of Revelation and say oh yeah okay
well that's what this means right here
and that's what this means and and okay
I've got it now
there's nothing wrong with I guess
coming up with theories about what it
might all mean and that could be very
interesting to do I'm not opposed to
that but for a person to get dogmatic
and this is what I've noticed about some
I think a lot of Christians today not
just kind of kostol but but a lot of
Christians in general where they get
very attached to the book of Revelation
and to their personal interpretation of
it and they're dogmatic about it and I
think that that's kind of ridiculous in
my opinion there's no way you can look
at that book and say I know exactly what
that means because you don't you just
stop you you've got you've got creatures
with with multiple heads and various
eyes you've got lampstands and all these
things coming out this guy and horses
and chariots and clearly with most this
stuff it's the it's not we're not
talking about literal imagery its
metaphor dydt allegory I mean it is
saying something but I don't think you
can just crack it open and be able to
tell exactly what it what it's trying to
tell you
one other point here I think is the most
important point it's important for us to
understand that Christians have been
predicting the imminent end of the world
literally since the beginning since the
very first Christian decade since the
very beginning of the church I mean from
day one Christians have thought that the
end is coming soon
right away within a within a few years
at least that's what Christians thought
and I know that sometimes people are
uncomfortable admitting this I don't
know why but it's true you can find it
even in the Bible it seems clear to me
that that Paul thought the world was
ending that seems pretty clear to me
when you read his letters he was wrong
obviously and that's okay Paul was not
omniscient we don't have to think that
the early Christians were omniscient or
the Paul was in the or that Eddy or that
any biblical writer was omniscient none
of them were so if it if Paul her if
these Christians personally believe that
Christ would be coming back very shortly
which I think they all did that's okay
you know they were wrong about that and
they're probably wrong about a lot of
other things too because like I said
they're not God and then through the
ages this belief continues there there
are always Christians who think the
world is ending
you know the first century second
century third century everything every
single century right so in in in the
year 120 people say oh no it's
definitely coming now and then 220 no
it's definitely coming now 320
definitely coming now 420 definitely
coming 720 definitely coming guys
1520 oh yeah the end is coming it's got
to happen now 1820 oh yeah it's
happening for sure now 1920 oh man for
sure it's happening now 2020 no this
time this time I'm telling you and so
after a while everyone's predicting an
imminent end for 2,000 years 20
centuries at what point do we just admit
that we have no clue when the world's
gonna end
we have no idea I mean the world could
end tomorrow it could go on for another
ten thousand years we could go on for
another ten million years who knows at
what point do we admit that and if we
could only step back and take a
historical view for
the moment we would see how silly these
doomsday forecasts are yeah there are
things about the modern day that are bad
to say the least but apocalyptic think
about it up to up to 50 percent of
Europe's population was wiped out by the
Black Plague in just a few years in the
14th century that's well over a hundred
million people if not up - not if not up
to two hundred million people in terms
of doomsday scenarios that out does
anything we have ever seen or probably
ever will see hopefully so do you think
they had reason to believe that the
world was ending back in the back in the
1300s well yeah they did but the world
didn't end or think about when Rome fell
I mean the Roman Empire ruled for a
thousand years do you think people had
reason to think apocalyptic things when
that ancient empire was laid in ruins
can you imagine can you imagine and I
think this is what this is what's
happening that we look around and we see
things happening in our civilization
with our country and we saw it's the end
of the world well it may be or or maybe
it could be you know our country could
end I'm not saying that it is going to
but our country could come to an end our
civilization can come to an end that
doesn't mean that the world is ending
many civilizations throughout history
have collapsed and and yet the world
continued going on our country has only
been around for a measly 250 years if
our country collapsed tomorrow and
didn't exist anymore honestly 500 years
from now the United States will be a
blip on the radar it would hardly even
be discussed because of how because of
how how short its existence was the
comparison with like ancient Rome or
ancient China or Egypt I mean these
things are these these these empires
were around for thousands of years and
we are just babies compared to that
we've barely even gotten started so my
point is that if bad things are
happening in America that doesn't mean
that the world is hinting I mean we just
got here for goodness sakes so the
problem is that we're stuck in our own
era with our own experiences our own
lives and we just assume that everything
happening to us is unprecedented
hugely important catastrophic historic
so on and so on when really that's not
the case necessarily right and anyway
none of this matters really because
here's what we do know for sure we don't
know what revelation is telling us
exactly we don't know when our
civilization or world will come to an
end but you do know absolutely that as
far as you are concerned the world will
end within 80 years at tops probably
right as far as you're concerned the
world is coming to an imminent end sorry
so your world will end in a few decades
if not sooner
the world may go on for another 500
million years but your world will end I
mean practically in the blink of an eye
so because of your death right so
imagine if Jesus appeared in the sky and
told us that the world would end in the
year twenty eighty seven let's say we
would all react very strongly to that
wouldn't we we would we it would change
the way we live the way we operated yet
Jesus essentially has told us the world
will end in the year 2020 87 or much
sooner for us because he's given us a
life span that probably won't last much
longer than 85 or 90 years at the most
yet it's like it's as if we need to
think that the whole world is ending in
order to act with any urgency which is
silly because what is it even in a sense
I mean what does even matter when the
world ends you're going to end soon
whether the whole world goes with you or
not is almost like a minor detail really
as far as you're concerned and your soul
is concerned so maybe we should be less
focused on the fate of the entire world
and more focused on our own fate and and
on our own mortality and on our own
imminent demise which which it which
indeed for us is is certainly imminent
alright this is from
heavenly says hey Matt first off I love
your podcast they give great insight
I always appreciate good sarcasm I'm a
22 year old woman I'm just starting to
get into the dating scene with the
intention of marriage and starting a
family my question is aside from kids
and religion is there other important
values and goals to people should share
in order to have a lasting marriage do
you think it's deeply important that
they agree on doctrine how much should
someone be willing to change or give up
for someone else thanks keep up the good
work all right so those are three
separate questions all are pretty deep I
will try not to drone on too long what
are their values and goals should two
people share well you mentioned kids in
religion already certainly you want to
be sure that your future spouse is
interested in having kids not just
theoretically but really wants to have
kids a marriage where one person wants
kids and the other does the other
doesn't can be disastrous and then
obviously you need to be sure that you
both have values that are rooted in
eternity in the eternal and God and
faith and so you already mentioned that
beyond that I don't think you need to
have a one-to-one match on every
fundamental value and goal that you have
I think what's more important is that
once you have those really basic things
down the next step is to make sure that
this person is someone with virtue okay
so somebody who's honest generous
trustworthy if you've got the basics
aligned and your spouse is virtuous then
the other difference is are not only not
a problem but they they could add
variety and interest and intrigue to
your relationship they could be positive
so I think and they give you something
you know they give you guys something to
talk about and work through together
which isn't a bad thing at all as for
doctrine again I would personally say
that if you have the first base covered
then as I just discussed I'm not sure
that the finer points of doctrine should
get in the way of marriage to someone I
mean if you find a man who has with whom
your fundamental values are aligned and
who wants kids and wants a family would
seem like he be a good father who is
virtuous honest trustworthy and faithful
then in my opinion
you know I think that's it'd be a good
idea to just pull the trigger honestly
it would probably be fullhart foolhardy
to say well yeah he's got all that going
for him but I'm not sure if our
theological view views are 100%
identical I think that you know that
would be a miss ordering of priorities
how much should you be willing to change
or give up well I would say maybe this
would surprise you to hear but don't
change any of the good things about
yourself don't compromise certainly
don't compromise your virtue don't give
up good and healthy things for someone
else and and the reason I say that is is
that a good partner and a good spouse
would never want you to give up those
things in the first place so there's no
reason why you should why you should
have to and I'm not just talking about
virtuous attributes here obviously you
don't want to give those up but I'm
talking even about healthy interests
hobbies passions you shouldn't you
shouldn't have to give those up either
like for instance I love to read I'm a
huge nerd and I'm either reading a book
physically or I'm listening to audio
book all the time my wife is not a big
reader herself and when we got married I
wasn't going to give up that part of
myself not that I'm saying that that
part of nothing I'm saying reading a
book is more important than my marriage
but I wasn't going to give that up you
know that's something I still want to do
and I'm gonna do it then it wasn't an
issue because my wife didn't want me to
give it up she wouldn't want me to in
fact actually if she notices that I go a
few days without reading something she
gets kind of concerned she says well I
haven't seen you read anything in a few
days what's going on and my wife has
healthy interests and passions and
skills that I don't share but I wouldn't
want her to give up the point is that a
healthy relationship should not entail
you forfeiting your whole identity your
identity rather than shrinking
contracting should expand and grow more
diverse and interesting through marriage
if anything you know I think it's sad
when you find people that they get
married and then they start giving up
these things that they're passionate
it should go the other way like you
should you should gain passions and
interests because of the influence of
the other person so for instance my wife
before she met me didn't drink bourbon
and Hall and how she tricks bourbon all
the time which maybe isn't a good thing
I like to say it's because that's an
interest that I have and she is uh she
has adopted it as well either that or
I'd driven her to drink I don't know but
you know the point is I think you you
pick up on these things from each other
so if you if you find someone who
expects you to be just a bland copy of
themselves and to give up everything
else in life that you love and are
passionate about then that again is a
good indication that this person is not
marriage material and you might as well
hide the other direction in essence I'm
saying that you shouldn't necessarily
have to give up or change anything that
is good and edifying in your life just
because you got married you might have
to adjust some things rework your
schedule and so on you won't be able to
do everything you want when you want to
but I don't see why marriage should
involve the absolute forfeiture of any
good thing it will or should however
involve the forfeiture of a lot of bad
things bad habits bad inclinations bad
aspects of yourself those things you
should give up in a marriage and it
would be a lot easier if you do alright
let's see no ok one other quick one it's
not even really a quick one this is from
sandy says hey Matt I just started
watching your show after watching
Shapiro for two years I enjoy the fact
you covered different but yet important
important topics my question for you
would be do what extent can morality be
derived from reason if at all you guys
are hit me with the hitting me with the
heavy guns today and it's great I love
it this isn't really one that I can just
throw in with the final two minutes of
the show but I'll try to anyway so to
what extent could morality be derived
from reason I would say that we all have
an innate moral sense natural law we all
recognize intuitively I guess you could
say reasonably through reason the basic
moral truths of life which is why when
you look around the world - throughout
history you're going to find all these
civilizations
fine you have
remarkably similar moral codes similar
in the basic structure anyway not
necessarily similar in practice or
interpretation so for example every
human civilization has outlawed murder
yet some human civilizations have
practiced human sacrifice genocide in
our case abortion these are all
redundant terms anyway basically saying
the same thing but none of those
civilizations that tolerated or
committed such atrocities would have
considered the atrocities murder
now it they were murder it is murder but
the point is that even the murderers
felt the need to work around pay lip
service to this moral code that even
they recognized so as reasonable beings
I think yes we can arrive at rudimentary
moral truths through reason and this is
a sense a recognition of rudimentary
moral truths that God instills in us but
for the fullness of those truths for the
full picture as it were we turn to
revelation and that's the way that I
would break that down in two minutes all
right we'll leave it there thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
Godspeed
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Noel's show the president came out
swinging on Saturday describing the need
for immigrants to learn English and
assimilate the surprising thing here is
that the president was Barack Obama and
not Donald Trump we will analyze the
open border policies of Democrats and
then it turns out we're all Eric's whoa
well check it out at daily wire com